FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LATEST
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL OF SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. TODAY WE HAVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET THIS
REVIEW COMMITTEE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. SENATOR STERN INSTEAD
TO MORALE. IF YOU HAVE SUPPORT
STAFF WITH YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY THEM NOW. YES I HAVE-
JEREMY WOLF WITH ME HERE IN THE
DISTRICT OFFICE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORALE. CAL IS HERE
WITH ME. WANT TO SEE WHAT TO DO
IF TO SEE REBEL. NOW TAKE. WERE
KILLED LAST NAME PLEASE SENATOR.
TAURUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WOULD REMIND OUR TO COLLEAGUES
TO REALIZE WHO THANK YOU SIR TO
MORALE AND REMINDER TO
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THAT
WHEN IT COMES TIME TO VOTE AND
DURING A ROLL CALL IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FIRST
THEN THE ACTION SENATOR STERN
PRESENT AND SENATE TO MORALE HI
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
RECORDS ARE ACCURATE CERTAIN.
AGAIN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN THE ACTIONS. WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTATIONDEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WERE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY ARE
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE NEW
PHONES OUR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AIDED ELIMINATING ANY
CO. FEED I AFTER EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THE TO
USE THAT QUOTE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE. IN THE PROGRAM EACH
TIME YOU RECOGNIZE THE SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON YOU
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING IT
PERSONNEL HERE WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. AND AGAIN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY.
HELLO THE PUBLIC AT WE A
LIMITED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL THIS IS THE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE AND ACCESS IS POSTED
IN ON OUR COMMUTE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND THAT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. LET ME
ALSO ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT CALLING NUMBER IS
ONE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE THREE. FIVE
FIVE. ONE SEVEN FIVE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THE WORK
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE IN
ORDER COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY THE END TO
AVOID A CLOSE TO FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU WERE.
BEING THE HEARING. PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO DESTRUCTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT THE HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. CALLING WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON THE AGENDA FOR TODAY AB
ONE OH SIX RELATED TO STATE
BARGAINING UNITS BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR SEPARATE
SEVEN SO IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. SENATORS MITCHELL.
MITCHELL PRESENT RESIDENT
NIELSEN THERE LISTEN HERE BILL.
BILL HERE ZERO HERE HERE HERE
DOLLY ERIC DOLLY HERE DORADO.
PRESENT HERE THE TITLE. HER
DAUGHTER PRESENT LEYVA A PAPER
HERE MCGUIRE AIR CRIER HERE
MELENDEZ HERE. MULLIN IS HERE
MONEY HERE MONNING HERE MORE
LOCK PRESENT OR NOT PRESENT
MORALE. HERE MOREAU HERE PAN
HERE AND HERE WE'RE ALL HERE.
ROB HERE SKINNER. STERN THIRTY
HERE TURN HERE WHAT COUNTY HERE
WIECKOWSKI HERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE CONSULTANT NOTICES THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM SO WE'LL
GO WILL COMMENCE THE HEARING.
WITH AB ONE ALL SIX OF THE OF
FINANCE TODAY WILL RECEIVE FROM
MERRY HOLTERMANN GOOD MORNING
MISS HOFFMAN THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH THIS. MORNING THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME THIS MORNING.
HI MERRY HELL TO RENT APARTMENT
A FINANCE AB ONE OH SIX
RATIFIES THE SIDE LETTER
AGREEMENT ENTERED INTO BY THE
STATE AND INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS FOR
STATE PARTY BARGAINING UNITS.
MAINTENANCE WORKERS AND
THIRTEEN OPERATING ENGINEERS.
THE ALTHOUGH THE STATE RATIFIED
THE BARGAINING UNIT TWELVE AND
SUCCESSOR AMMO YOU PRIOR TO
JULY FIRST I YOU ARE YOU ARE WE
DID NOT HAVE THE AGREEMENT
RATIFIED BY JULY ONE. AS SUCH
THIS EYELINER WAS STATE
BARGAINING UNIT TWELVE IS
RELATED TO THE STATE'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY FOR LOW POLICY AND
IMPACTS OF THIS POLICY FOR JULY
TWENTY TWENTY. THAT EACH FULL
TIME EMPLOYEE. UNIT DURING THE
JULY TWENTY EIGHT. WILL BE A
OUR OF PROGRAM HOURS TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT AND THAT
THE EMPLOYEES BEING SUBJECT TO
A NINE POINT 23% FOR LOW
PAYROLL DEDUCTION WHILE
CONTINUING TO FIND THEIR OTHER
POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. AND
THE SIDE LETTER WHAT STATE
BARGAINING UNIT THIRTEEN FOR
THE TERM OF JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO REPRESENTS
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION SAVINGS
OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS SIX
POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL
FIND. IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND IT INCLUDES A
NINE POINT 23% PAYROLL
DEDUCTION SIXTEEN HOURS
CREDITED MONTHLY FOR THE
PERSONALLY PROGRAM GETTING IN
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY. S. AS AN
EXAMPLE. MISSION PRE FUNDING
HAD. I'M WITH THE AUGUST WHEN
TWENTY EIGHT AND- SO IN TOTAL
ALL OF THE AGREEMENTS INCLUDING
THE ONES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED. I RESULT IN EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION SAVINGS AT TWO
POINT SEVEN FOUR BILLION OR
WHICH IS ONE POINT NINE THREE
BILLION GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
THIS BILL ALSO MAKES A
CONFORMING STATUTORY CHANGES
FOR THE BERRIES AGREEMENTS THAT
WERE ENTERED INTO BY JUNE
THIRTIETH BY THE STATE AND THE
VARIOUS EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING STATE BARGAINING
UNITS. 778-910-1216 EIGHTEEN
AND NINETEEN. THAT WERE FIRED
FIRST AB ONE NINETY. AND THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHERE NOTICED OF ALL
OF THESE AGREEMENTS ON JULY
EIGHT. TIMES AND LASTLY THIS
BILL APPROPRIATE FIVE POINT
NINE MILLION THREE POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES RELATED TO
START STATE BARGAINING UNITS TO
SEVEN EIGHT TWELVE THIRTEEN AND
SIXTEEN. BUT I AM AVAILABLE TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT
MISS HOFFMAN QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR MORE LAW. THANK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT TO.
ANOTHER ONE ASK QUESTIONS YOU
JUST MAKE SOME OBSERVATIONS AND
MAYBE- MISS HOLDEN COULD
CONFIRM WHETHER I'M
UNDERSTANDING THE PROVISIONS OF
THESE CONTRACTS- BUT CURRENTLY
THE STATE PAYS- INTO THE
RETIREE MEDICAL PLAN BUT IT'S
DONE THROUGH A 4% WITHHOLDING.
FROM EACH EMPLOYEE A SINCE WERE.
STATING THAT WERE REDUCING THE
SALARIES BY NINE POINT 23% BUT
WE'RE ALSO NOT REUIRING THE
WITHHOLDING OF 4% WERE ACTUALLY
MAYBE JUST HAVING OR A NET
REDUCTION OF. FIVE POINT TWO
THREE PERCENT. AND IT APPEARS
THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE TAKING
A REDUCTION IN HOURS THOSE
HOURS ARE BEING. SET ASIDE AND-
A DEFERRED PROGRAM TO LIKE GET
SICK LEAVE OR VACATION UNUSED
TIME SO I'M WONDERING. ABOUT
TWO THINGS ONE- IF WE'RE NOT
PAYING IN THE 4% THAT MEANS%
THAT THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY FOR
THE RETIREE MEDICAL PLAN IS
INCREASING BY A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER. I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE-
SUPPOSED TO HAVE AS AN ASSUME
RATE OF RETURN FOR THE RETIREE
MEDICAL PLAN. BUT IF IT'S THE
SAME AS CALPERS THAT WOULD BE
7% SO THAT'S- TEN TIMES THE
RATE. THAT THE GOVERNMENT- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S BORROWING
AT FOR TEN YEAR TREASURIES AT
POINT SIX. SO IT'S PRETTY
EXPENSIVE. DEAD AND WERE.
ACTUALLY NOT REDUCING WAGES
WERE JUST DEFERRING WAGES FROM
WHAT I READ. SO I'M JUST KIND
OF CONCERNED THAT MIGHT ALSO BE
AN INTERESTING LOAN THAT WERE
WERE ACTUALLY TAKING OUTSIDE I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
I UNDERSTAND THAT THOSE
COMPONENTS RECORD THAT I MIGHT
HAVE A COUPLE FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR. AND SO-
EITHER FINANCE WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE LET
DOWN WITH THE OFFICE WHO ARE
AVAILABLE IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE
TO LEARN RESPOND TO THE SENATOR.
MERRY ALTERMAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I AM IS SO FOR THE
EMPLOYEE- PAD AMOUNTS SO IT
VARIES BY BARGAINING UNITS- I
DON'T REMEMBER THE EXACT
AMOUNTS IT RANGES FROM ABOUT 2%
SIEU I BELIEVE THE HIGHEST IS
FOUR POINT. 6% A SO YES THOSE
WOULD BE SO. FOR THE TERMS OF
THE- THAT WORK RETAIL I'M SOME
OF THEM ARE FOR ONE YEAR SOME
OF THEM HAVE AGREED TO TWO
YEARS. AND THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WOULD BE
THAT WOULD BE FAR GONE AND
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE ESTIMATE TO BE SIX
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MILLION IN
TOTAL FOR ALL OF THE BARGAINING
UNITS. I WHICH IS THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION GENERAL
FINDS. AIRLINES I DON'T HAVE
THE EXACT NUMBER IN FRONT OF ME
BUT THE EM RATE OF RETURN FOR
THE HEALTH PLANS. THE ANNUAL
EVALUATION. THANK JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH
WAS THE LAST ONE IT WAS I
BELIEVE AROUND FOUR POINT 25%
IT WAS IN THE 4% AREA SO IT'S
SLOW WORK IT SEEMS RATE OF
RETURN NINE HELP. AT THE MOMENT.
SO AB I'M JUST KIND CARRIER
WHO'S WHO TO GO. THESE
CONTRACTS IS IT STAFF IN THE
GOVERNOR'S FOR YOU RETAIN AN
INDEPENDENT. SAY LAW FIRM TO
NEGOTIATE. AS NEGOTIATED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION I'M CALLIE CHARS
DE DESIGNATED REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. SO I
GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO
DETERMINE IS BY VOTING FOR THIS
I'M NOT REALLY REDUCING
ANYTHING I'M JUST DEFERRING.
COSTS I WILL STE SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE WAY THAT THE STATE
WILL HAVE TO PAY THEIR OKAY
COSTS IN SUMMER ALONG THE WAY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY
MAYBE WHEN. HE'S EMPLOYEES
RETIRE- THEIR BACK WAGES THAT
WERE SET ASIDE TIME. I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE. RECEIVING
ANYTHING WE JUST IS IT JUST A
TIMING FIND. THE FINES ARE
BEING SAGE I'M AND IT
IMMEDIATELY AND THE CURRENT
YEAR. AND STAFF ARE RECEIVING
HOURS THAT THEY CAN TAKE EITHER
NOW OR IN THE FUTURE. I'M AND
WITH THE CATAMOUNTS BEING
SUSPENDED FOR ONE OR TWO YEARS.
AND THAT WOULD GO TOWARDS THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A THIRTY YEAR
PLANS YOU PAY OFF THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY. SO AT THIS POINT WE
DON'T KNOW IF THAT WOULD
DELAYED THE THIRTY YEAR AND.
PROJECTION WE DON'T HAVE AN
UPDATED. IF THE CONCLUDE MADAM
CHAIR AT THE COUNTY BOARD WE-
STAY WITH HOPE HAVE HAVING A
WERE HOLD FOR OKAY IN THE
COUNTY JUST PAY FOR ITSELF. SO
THIS MIGHT BE IN FUTURE YEARS
IF THINGS CONTINUE TO BE A
LITTLE TIGHT. IT MIGHT BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE A REYES
WITHOUT GIVING REYES YOU CAN
JUST GO AHEAD AND- PULL OUT THE
4% OR WHATEVER THE TWO AND A
HALF TWO TO FOUR POINT 6% AND
THEN HAVE THE STATE PAY FOR
ITSELF SO WE STAY ON TRACK AND
WE'RE NOT DEPENDENT ON SOME OF
THESE CYCLES- BECAUSE THIS IS A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT LIABILITY
FROM. MY UNDERSTANDING IT'S
OVER A SIX BILLION DOLLARS AND
NOW IT'S GONNA GROW CLOSE TO
NINETY BILLION THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY FOR. DOES IT FOLLOW US-
ESPECIALLY OUR KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS ART. EIGHT I'D LIKE
TO SEE MAYBE EVEN A
RENEGOTIATION OF OUR OKAY A
PLAN. A WE DID AT THE COUNTY.
JUST FOR SOME MINOR TWEAKS THAT
WAS A GROUP THEY WERE GREETED
BY THE BARGAINING UNITS AND WE
REDUCED OUR INPUT OF LIABILITY
BY 71% SO. 71% TIMES NINETY IS
A GOOD SIXTY BILLION WITH THE
TAKE OFF THE BALANCE SHEETS OF.
THEY HAVE BEEN TO AT THAT TO
BECAUSE THIS IS CERTAINLY A-
VERY HIGH ANNUAL COSTS THAT
WILL BE BORN FOR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I ALSO TO- JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON MAYBE A
LITTLE EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAD
WHEN I WAS A CASE SUPERVISORS
WELL. TO THE DIFFERING THOSE
OUT- SO A LOT OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES WILL GET STEP
INCREASES ALONG THE WAY. AND
THEY WILL ALSO. MAYBE IF YOUR
LONG COURSE THAT YOU BECOME A
SERGEANT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU BANK
THAT UP AND WHEN YOU GO TO
RETIRE. ON YOUR TO HIGHER
SALARY AND SO REALLY YOUR YOUR
CALL FOR YOU YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE
NOT BASED AT THE TIME WHEN THEY
SET IT ASIDE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
BASED. AT THE TIME. WHEN HE
RETIRES SO THAT'S A DOUBLE HIT
TO THE BUDGET IN FUTURE YEARS
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT- THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
TAKE AND IT. INTO CONSIDERATION
AS WELL. BECAUSE YOUR REAL
REALLY GETTING A DOUBLE HIT
BECAUSE A LOT OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES ARE GOING TO GET.
THEY'RE GONNA GET CALLS ALONG
THE WAY AND ALSO GOING TO GET.
MAYBE A STEP INCREASE IN SO
WHEN YOU RETIRE YOU YOU'RE AT
YOUR HIGHEST YOU'RE PAID OUT.
AND IF IT'S TEN YEARS FROM NOW.
THAT COULD BE A HECK OF A LOT
MORE MONEY IN NY TIMES AT
TIMES. THE MOUNT EMPLOYEES THAT
ARE GOOD THIS A FAX- THIS IS
NOT GOOD BUSINESS TO DO THAT IT
IS IT COULD BE IT IS NOT SAID
AT THE- AT THE RATE TODAY. IS
THE SENATE THEIR FUTURE
RETIREMENT DATE SO. THAT THAT'S
ANOTHER THING THAT THE LA OWES
OFFICE IN THE BUDGET. FOLKS
SHOULD TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
WHEN THEY PUT TOGETHER A PLAN
LIKE THIS. THANK YOU SIR.
QUESTION FOR MEMBERS. NO HAN
SEEING NO HANDS REYES FROM MY
REMOTE MEMBERS IN THE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS HALF QUESTION. SENATOR
KNOWLEDGE. THANK YOU I DO HAVE
A FOLLOW UP QUESTION SO THAT
THOSE EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE HOURS
BAIT- IN THEIR RETIREMENT ARE
THEY REQUIRED TO BURN THOSE
HOURS- NOW OR THEY ALLOWED TO
CARRY THOSE HOURS ON BECAUSE
THAT WILL IMPACT AS WELL
RETIREMENT IF THEY CARRY THOSE
HOURS YEAR YEAR FORWARD. AND SO
IN ALL OF THE AGREEMENTS- IT
STATES THAT HE PERSONALLY OF
OURS ARE TO BE USED PRIOR TO
ALL OTHER LEAVE- EXCEPT FOR
SICK LEAVE AT THAT CHOOSING OF
THE EMPLOYEE. AND SO IT IS
EXPECTED THAT ALL THESE OUR
SHOULD BE USED FIRST. I'M IN
AND EMPLOYEESEPARATE AND THEY
ARE UNABLE TO USE HOURS PRIOR
TO SEPARATION THEN THEY WOULD
BE CASHED OUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL. ALL RIGHT
SINGING NINE. WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN REGARD AGAIN
TO AB ONE OH SIX. LET'S BEGIN
WITH WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN HEARING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. SCENE NINE.
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT BE THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MODERATOR IF YOU'D PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR AB
ONE ALL SIX WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
KILLING UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COULD YOU JUST
CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE TIME
BEFORE WE MOVE ON. AGAIN TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
GOING UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS MODERATOR YOUR
HELP DO WE HAVE A MOTION AB ONE
OH SIX. SOME WILL THANK YOU
CENTER I CASTING. THE MOVE IN
THE BUILDING MOVED BY CENTER BY
KATHY THE MOTION IS TO PASS. MR
STEPHENS SHOP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL YOU KNOW. TO START TO GET
SOME. MOTION TO PARA. CENTERS
MITCHELL. HI YEAH MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN KNOWS NOTHING NO THE
BILL HI BILL I CARRIER. BUREAU
ON DOLLY. DAWALY NO RATHER.
RESO HI HER DAUGHTER FOR TITLE
II LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I
OUR AYE MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ NO
MONEY. MORNING ARE MORE LONG.
NO WE'RE NO MORRELL. NO THE
REAL NO PAN. CAN I WRONG ROTH
AYE SKINNER. STERN STERN I
STERN ONLINE. BUT COUNTY. MY
COUNTY I. THE HI THE ELEVEN
KNOWS FIVE. FIVE ELEVEN KNOWS
FIVE THE MOTION CARRIES THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY. LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WITH
INCLUDE THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW IS A GIANT.